robert taylor has been acting
professionally for over 30 years but
he's only just reached that big open sky
of american stardom by playing the lead
role of the old-school wyoming sheriff
in the hit series longmire let's explore
the untold truth of how taylor made it
to the top
robert taylor spent his later childhood
years with his aunt and uncle in a
western australia mining town after his
parents split he worked for a local
company like most kids do unlike most
kids though that local company was mine
after working in the mines you'd think
he'd leave for something easier but when
he did leave the mines taylor went for
one of the most rough neck jobs a person
can take he worked on an oil rig as
taylor said in a dispatch article we
were three guys covered in crap in the
middle of the ocean in the middle of
nowhere hotter than hell you get hit by
cyclones
dealing with the dirty businesses of
mining and oil drilling no doubt got him
ready to navigate the tough road to
hollywood stardom the irony can't be
ignored though that walt longmire has
issues with lawless oilfield workers at
least it made him believable as a man
who's not intimidated by a couple of
guys with guns
speaking of that time as an oil
roughneck his time working and resource
extraction did in fact lead to his
acting career according to his interview
with dispatch he said one time we sank
the biggest ship off the west coast of
australia since world war ii i was the
youngest guy on board and we got them
all off because we breached the bulkhead
to the engine room and if you do that
you're going down taylor was injured in
that crash and the ensuing castaway
adventure ending his harrowing tale of
survival in the hospital then he saw an
ad to audition for a school of dramatic
arts he said i had never met anyone who
had a creative thought or an interesting
haircut or anything like that but i saw
this ad in the paper and i figured i'd
gotten banged up pretty bad on the ship
so they would be chopping me off and so
i thought i would audition so he did
the drama school robert taylor
auditioned for was western australian
academy of performing arts in perth
taylor told dispatch if you get in you
don't pay anything you are on a full
scholarship i had classical training for
three years i started that in 84 and
graduated in 86 so i have done this for
a long time
graduating from wapa put taylor in the
esteemed company a fellow alumni hugh
jackman who's known not only for playing
the savage wolverine in the x-men films
but also for being comfortable as a
singing and dancing musical star that
makes sense since wapa is known as a top
incubator for musical theater as a 2014
sydney morning herald article put it
talented graduates of the leading
performing arts school wapa flow into
musicals all over the country and world
of course it does have a program just
for actors according to the herald
article quote the acting course accepts
about 18 students from 700 to 800
applicants proof that taylor obviously
had some natural acting jobs
robert taylor's most famous role to this
point is sheriff walt longmire it isn't
a big surprise though since he started
his career playing cops his early roles
read like a police station roll call the
shows and tv movies are unfamiliar to
americans since they're mostly
australian and british but the
characters have names like constable
hanks constable healy and constable
gutly
he even had a seven episode arc as
detective peter morenta in yellow thread
street however after landing a recurring
role on a soap opera called home and
away he went back to playing detectives
almost as if he was moving up in the
police department taylor went from parts
with the titles officer and constable to
roles like detective barry gregg
detective sergeant mick foley and
detective constable porter eventually he
got the big promotion every cop dreams
of and became the sheriff of a whole
county a county with three deputies
which wouldn't even equal half the
number of lawmen taylors played in his
career
robert taylor spent years acting an
australian shows and tv movies but his
big hollywood breakthrough was playing
another man of authority one who serves
not so great overlords agent jones in
the matrix
yes agent smith is the lead antagonist
to neo in the movie but agent jones has
one of the most famous scenes he's the
guy who dodges every one of neo's
bullets before trinity dispatches in
point blank with the timeless line
only human
dodge this
the matrix was robert taylor's first
appearance in front of the big american
movie crowd and his strong jaw and
authoritarian bearing made him
unforgettable even while playing a
faceless virtual agent who doesn't have
a whole lot to say other than longmire
it's still one of his biggest roles and
was even mentioned as his big credit
when he landed longmire and given the
many times walt longmire's been shot i
bet he wishes he could dodge bullets
like agent jones
aisha davies is kind of a big deal down
under she's been working in production
since 1999 but her big producer credits
are for several shorts and a few
features those features coffin rock and
what lola wants coincidentally star you
guessed it robert taylor as with
everything else connected to robert
taylor details about their private life
together are scarce at least one website
claims they've been dating since 2002.
most media sources mentioned they have a
daughter named scarlet and as with all
the other details it's tough to find
fully confirmed information about her
beyond her name it can be confirmed that
taylor and davies were married in 2017
on a ranch in wyoming the photo a simple
facebook post from hf bar ranch shows
the tailors in what looks to be a young
girl presumably their daughter based on
the fact that she's standing up there
she was likely born before they got
married but since the tailors obviously
want some privacy it's best not to pry
beyond that
robert taylor is a man of many talents
and interests from a youth spent surfing
lifeguarding playing australian rules
football and roughnecking to his long
and illustrious acting career he can add
one more thing to his cv however
community garden organizer in saint
kilda australia taylor is president of
veg out while this isn't mentioned in
much official press for the community
gardens organization an article in the
age specifically made the connection
describing a place where local farmers
had been quote transforming a former
bowling green and saint kilda into an
inner city oasis called veg out the
article confirmed the actor's role
saying
actor rob taylor who is the star of
netflix hit longmire is the garden's
long-standing president when he's not
playing a sheriff in the u.s crime drama
rob can be found strolling down the tan
bark paths and blunt stones with a
handful of weeds in his hands this is
where he feels at home
author craig johnson has written quite a
few walt longmire novels if you think
taylor's turn as walt longmire has him
reading up on his character to get all
the nuances of the character right well
that'd be a no he did it all on his own
i don't think so
i know so
as the actor said in a seattle times
article i have been waiting for a long
time for a show like this you always
work hard to get a part that you want as
the article also explains he hasn't read
all the longmire adventures the actor
read the first two books before
realizing there were enough differences
between the books and the show that he
should stop reading according to the
article taylor planned to read all of
the books in the series when the show
was over now that his time is up and
longmire is no more you have to wonder
if taylor has finally cracked the other
15 spines yet
it's tough for an aussie actor to
audition in america given that the two
countries are separated by the pacific
ocean but increasingly actors from
overseas have auditioned over video
which was perfect for robert taylor as
he explained in a collider interview
hollywood sends out creative briefs all
over the world to the main acting hubs
including australia taylor was drawn to
walt longmire so he decided to audition
remotely he said in the interview that
he simply had a friend film his audition
with the camera and then sent it off to
the united states eventually forgetting
about it as time went on elaborating
further he said i remember after a month
or so i thought oh i never heard back oh
well that happens all the time and then
that day i got a call and they said they
want you to go to la and do another
audition apparently video auditioning is
taylor's mo he confirmed that's the way
i like to audition i prefer to do it
privately and secretly i've sent stuff
to london and then flown there one time
i flew over there and went in the room
for the final audition and they said
congratulations you've got the job
classic walt longmire staying home on
the ranch as much as possible
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]